all right gary eduardo congratulations
guys your hard work has paid off and is
now down to the two of you battling out
for the title of fortune fire champion
and that check for 10 grand and because
this competition's all about iconic
weapons from south america we're
sticking with that theme we're giving
you four days to build this
the argentinian sabre
the argentinian sabre was a fierce 19th
century weapon used by the cavalry
soldiers known as the argentinian
grenadiers
these mounted warriors used the
lightweight single-edged blade to
deliver swift and lethal slashes against
enemies while the large hilt protected
their hands
after their crucial service in the
argentinian war of independence the
grenadiers were given the honor of
becoming the presidential escort guard
today these elite soldiers still protect
the president with this powerful saber
at their sides all right guys we will
see you in four days good luck dude
my name is eduardo sol i am originally
from mexico i moved to the us because i
was a foreign exchange student during
college and met the woman of my dreams
she got me interglax with me and i got
hooked on lives my concern is that pipe
back's fine here we go i never knew that
existed until today the biggest
challenge is putting in the curve that's
a requirement while still keeping the
pipe back spine intact help we've made
some serious progress
forging is going really well that's good
enough it's close enough and i am ready
for the quench
the blade is hard the blade is straight
and i am exhausted all i need to do now
is get started on my hilt
one of the parameters just drilling the
piercings in the hill
there's that disc these rotary discs are
literally exploding as soon as i put
them on the guard is too hard for the
rotary discs to cook through
this one line right there took two and a
half cutting discs i am extremely
aggravated by this i want to do 50
dremel discs this is supposed to be
quick and easy i am burning through my
day
i'm falling behind i hope i'm gonna have
enough time
all righty now to make that pretty
i finally
finish the piercings on my guard i am
down to a single
rotary disc left but i'm running out of
time i need to fly through my handle
hopefully everything's gonna marry up
perfectly that's it
overall i'm still on schedule
after i peen this on
and close it i'm gonna grind this extra
steel off so it's a much tighter fit to
the handle
it's time to paint the guard
and then sharpen my blade
that should be it it's really coming out
great
that is sharp
[Music]
i'm gary graham from elkilon alabama
12 days after i turned 18. i enlisted in
the army flying uh-60 blackhawks started
making my first blade after i got home
from deployment and it continued to grow
to a small business now i forged the
blade out got the length i want out of
it got it forced to shape drawing it out
with my dies and verifying that
everything's nice and even it's looking
good it's time to go sharpen the blade
so i'm at the point now i can go out and
do some testing with my blade
i bent my blade
i come out with a blade looking like a
boomerang damn i only got one more day
to get it done there's no time to waste
i've got to get working on a new blade
immediately and make this one work we
should have the process down pat now
we're good on parameters it's been a
hell of a day but then i've got a quench
blade
this blade looks a lot better and the
blade that didn't work out so great it's
time for me to work on my handle on my
heel
i grab a piece of sheet metal cut out
the shape that i want and i start
shaping it in swage block now i'm going
to cut these piercings into my heel
my plan to put this handle together to
secure it properly is i want to notch
out my tang
weld in a machine boat with a spacer so
i can tighten it all up
and the last thing i need to do is
sharpen it and assemble the sword that's
it for round three it's in the judge's
hands now
[Music]
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
keel test
it's time to find out just how lethal
your weapons are i'm gonna take your
weapons deliver some thrust and slashes
on this pig carcass gary you're first
you ready for this i'm ready let's do
this
since i've already warped one blade
during testing at home i'm nervous as a
cat on a high ten roof i don't want my
blade to crack i don't want it to warp
and i don't want it to break
so
[Music]
all right guys talk about your weapon
here first up most of the weight is
right in the very tip of this blade
but the saving grace for that is that
you have a nice handle right there where
i can grab on to it i can marry my hand
it's a void and i've got full control
with this weapon as you can see those
were very deep cuts overall sir your
weapon
it will kill
thank you
all right where are your turns are you
ready i'm excited let's go let's do this
i know my edge is fantastic it can take
a beating it's a killer blade i can't
wait to see what it can do
gentlemen i think we have a problem here
that's a very small handle
my hand barely fits in there and when
i'm swinging
there was just no retention or stop
right here especially the slashes we're
thrusting it with a forward wheat
all that is on my wrist what do you
think
i see what you're saying i can swing it
down i can't pull it back up because i
don't have the leverage yeah i'm looking
at my fingers double up
the problem is is there's no space in
there if it does cut loose that's
breaking my hand
is there any way to adjust and make it
fair the problem with that is i can hold
back to make it work but now i'm holding
back and that's not an even test anymore
okay you guys all agree blade's not safe
to wield
yes
okay
in water we absolutely hate to see a
competition end like this when wielding
an edged weapon safety is always of the
utmost importance due to the small
handle they've presented and the lack of
retention that it offers the judges have
issued a vote and no confidence they
can't safely test your weapon so
unfortunately your time in this
competition has ended i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor
congratulations buddy thank you
i'm crushed i'm disappointed
i worked really hard for it to not to
get tested it fit my hand perfectly
every step of this competition was a
learning experience and i really think
i'm leaving a better smith
gary you are today's fortune fire
champion you got yourself a check for
ten thousand dollars congratulations
thank you i really appreciate it
it feels great to be a fortune fire
champion what are you gonna do with the
10 grand you have plans no i'm sure my
wife does
i just want to savor this for a while
there's a lot of work to get here
it's been fun i've met a lot of great
people
and i've enjoyed it
you